[Musik]
deutschland ist das Land das in Sachen
Produktivität Lebensqualität und
menschlicher Entwicklung bisher fast
immer die oberen Plätze der weltweiten
Rankings gepachtet zu haben schien vor
allem seine große Wirtschaftsmacht wurde
von vielen Politikern Analysten und
Experten aller Art als echtes Vorbild
gesehen doch in letzter Zeit hat good
old Germany mit ganz anderen Arten von
Nachrichten immer mehr Schlagzeilen
gemacht damit meinen wir insbesondere
Dinge wie diese 21 April 2023 Berlin
nach der Pandemie steigt die
Kriminalitätsrate in der deutschen
Hauptstadt 4 November
2023 die deutsche Polizei fordert
messerfreie Zonen in den Städten 27
November
2023 zu viel Kriminalität zu wenig
Personal Bremens polizeichft schlägt
Alarm besonders schockierend ist der
Anstieg von Einbrüchen und
fahrzeugdiebstehl mittlerweile hat man
auch im Ausland bemerkt dass die Zahlen
der Verbrechen und vor allem der
Gewaltverbrechen im ein so sicher
geglaubten Deutschland derzeit sehr
stark ansteigen ganz zu schweigen davon
dass solche Probleme oft an Anzeichen
großer Armut eines hohen Maßes an
Ausgrenzung und einer unzureichenden
Strafverfolgung sind Deutschland eines
der reichsten und am weitesten
entwickelten Länder der Welt hatte
bisher eigentlich keines dieser Probleme
und trotzdem steigen die
Kriminalitätszahlen plötzlich in die
Höhe offiziellen Polizeiangaben zufolge
sieht sich das Land einer immer stärker
anschwellenden Welle von Raubüberfällen
Morden sexual Verbrechen und
Menschenhandel konfrontiert in dieser
Hinsicht leben die Deutschen heute
tatsächlich im schlimmsten Deutschland
der vergangenen
Jahrzehnte und tatsache ist dass trotz
vieler Warnungen die Situation vor nicht
allzu langer Zeit ganz anders war noch
im Jahr 2019 hat sich Deutschland mit
folgendem gebrüstet 8 mai 2018
Deutschland verzeichnet die niedrigste
Kriminalitätsrate seit
2092 4 Februar 2019 die
Kriminalitätsrate in Deutschland fällt
auf den niedrigsten Stand seit
Jahrzehnten was zum Teufel ist also mit
der Kriminalität in Deutschland los wie
lässt sich diese Welle der Gewalt und
Unsicherheit erklären nun zieht euch
warm an denn heute werden wir kein Blatt
vor den Mund nehmen wir werden in aller
Gründlichkeit klären wie das einstige
Musterland überhaupt in eine derart
hararige Situation geraten konnte
apropos haarig euch ist sicher schon mal
aufgefallen dass ich ein ziemlich
haariger Typ bin und das nicht nur im
übertr igenen Sinne na ja ihr müsst ja
nur mal in meinen Ausschnitt gucken
lasst euch aber eines gesagt sein gerade
deswegen weiß ich dass man mit seiner
körperbeharung sehr Form und stilbewusst
umgehen muss fakt ist aber auch dass ich
früher immer dachte wer schön sein will
muss leiden da musst du als Mann halt
durch egal an welcher Stelle deines
Körpers du dich rasierst und so habe ich
jahrelang all den Schmerz und auch das
Blut ertragen bis ich nach vielen
Versuchen mit billig Rasierern und auch
markenschraut aller Art endlich auf
manscape gestoßen bin und nichts anderes
mehr will so wie übrigens sage und
schreibe 9 Millionen Männer weltweit und
heute sage ich mir dass mein Leid
eventuell nicht umsonst gewesen sein
muss wenn ich es nämlich wenigstens euch
ersparen kann deswegen möchte ich euch
das neue Pflegeset Performance Package
5.0 ultra an Herz legen mit dem das
manscape Team mal wieder Topqualität in
einem durchdachten Kombipaket abliefert
diese enthält den neuen lawnmower 550
ultra für eine perfekte Rasur an allen
erdenklichen Stellen deines Körpers den
wewacker 2 Ohren und nasenhaartrimmer
und feine intimflegeprodukte für den
ultimativen Komfort und Duft nach der
Rasur mit dem lohnmauer klappt jede
Intimrasur nicht nur perfekt und hoch
präzise nein wirklich unbezahlbar ist
vor allem das angenehme Gefühl dass sich
deine empfindlichsten Regionen in
sicheren Händen befinden das Gerät
verfügt über zwei neu entwickelte
skinsafe schneideaufsätze für
unterschiedliche Funktionen eine
klassische Klinge zum Trimmen und ein
Scherkopf zum glatt rasieren die
weiterentwickelte trimmerklinge
schneidet durch ihre längeren und
breiteren abgerundeten Zähne auch dicke
Haare Müh los ihr bekommt also einen
präzisionstdrimmer und einen
elektrischen Rasierer in einem Gerät
sehr praktisch ist auch das integrierte
LED Spotlight jetzt in zwei
unterschiedlichen Farbtemperaturen und
unterschiedlichen helligkeitsgraden und
das Beste daran wenn ihr den Link in der
Videobeschreibung und meinen Rabattcode
vp20 benutzt bekommt ihr das Performance
Package 5.0 ultra nicht nur per
kostenlosen Versand und mit satten 20%
Rabatt sondern auch noch zwei exklusive
Goodies gratis dazu ein schniakes paar
speziell Design der Boxershorts und
einen stilechten Kulturbeutel also
worauf wartest du noch tu deinen
kronjubelen endlich was Gutes und
kümmere dich standesgemäß um sie mit dem
Performance Package 5.0 ultra von
manscaped der Marke die weltweit das
Thema Männerpflege zum Lifestyle gemacht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hat
wenn wir über Geschichte sprechen ist es
wohl klar dass Deutschland ein Land ist
das verdammt viel durchgemacht hat meist
aus eigenem Antrieb aber auch durch
äußere Einflüsse allein im letzten
Jahrhundert hat es zwei Weltkriege
angezettelt seine Teilung erlebt den
heftigsten Territorialkonflikt des
Kalten Krieges dann die Vereinigung von
Ost und West die Gründung der
Europäischen Union und vieles mehr und
was eine Sicherheit angeht musste
Deutschland sicherlich schon einige
schwierige Zeiten durchmachen besonders
in den 1990er Jahren die
Wiedervereinigung der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland mit dem Trabanten der
Sowjetunion namens Deutsche
Demokratische Republik brachte viele
Probleme mit sich die Wiedervereinigung
bedeutete dass sich der kommunistischall
Deutschlands über Nacht an ein neue
Marktwirtschaft anpassen musste das
wiederum führte dazu dass viele
Staatsbetriebe schließen mussten und die
Arbeitslosigkeit in die Höhe schoss was
die Tatsache dass das Armutsniveau
bereits viel höher lag als im Westen
vorübergehend noch verschlimmerte hinzu
kamen viele Band aus anderen Ländern
Osteuropas die nach dem Fall des
Eisernen Vorhangs im Westen nun viel
freier operieren konnten man sprach
damals auch vom Erbe der durch die
Kommunisten induzierten präkarisierung
der ostdeutschen Bevölkerung damit war
die übertriebene Idealisierung des
einfach gestrickten Proletariats durch
das untergegangene Regime gemeint
tatkräftiger Unternehmergeist sozialer
Aufstieg ein selbstbewusstes Bürgertum
und unabhängige Intellektualität wurden
von ihm als etwas Unanständiges
gebrandmarkt mit so etwas konnte man in
der DDR und den anderen Länder des
Ostblocks nicht vorankommen durch den
permanenten Druck des Regimes hatten
sich viele Menschen dort entsprechend
angepasst und den inneren Antrieb
verloren die Werte des humanistischen
Bildungsbürgertums bei sich und
untereinander zu fördern Anstand
Rechtschaffenheit und Emanzipation waren
nur etwas von oben herabverordnetes
Gehorsam hatte die Identifikation der
Leute mit diesen Werten ersetzt und
kompensiert wurde dies durch das
Leitmotiv wer nicht die Öffentlichkeit
beklaut beklaut seine Familie
erschwerend kam hinzu dass die
ostdeutsche Polizei auf Sozi ale
Kontrolle Zensur und politische
Repression spezialisiert war sie musste
also von Grund auf umgestaltet werden
nicht nur operativ sondern auch
kulturell das Ergebnis nun wie euch
vorstellen könnt eine Landschaft die
besonders anfällig für die Ausbreitung
von Verbrechen ist natürlich hat sich
die wirtschaftliche Situation nach der
Wiedervereinigung verbessert sowohl
durch die Öffnung der Wirtschaft als
auch durch die enormen Hilfen die die
Bundesregierung für Ostdeutschland
bereitgestellt hat und diese
Verbesserung führte auch zu einem
Rückgang der Kriminalität die Sicherheit
im Osten Deutschland stieg wieder an in
den 1990er Jahren galt Ostdeutschland
als die Hochburg der Kriminalität in
Deutschland Mitte der 1990er Jahre war
die Kriminalität im Osten 20% höher als
im Westen dann ging die Kriminalität im
Osten allmähig zurück und war 2009 zum
ersten Mal niedriger als im Westen
infolgedessen konnte Deutschland sein
Sicherheitsniveau fast auf den
europäischen Durchschnitt verbessern
heute steht Gesamtdeutschland besser da
als Länder wie Frankreich Schweden oder
Italien aber schlechter als manche
andere wie z.B Polen Irland Portugal
Tschechien Estland denemark Slowenien
Kroatien oder Österreich okay also sagen
wir einfach dass der Anstieg der
Kriminalitätsrate nur vorübergehend war
er war eine vorübergehende nach wee des
Falls des Eisernen Vorhangs aber Achtung
denn bei der Zunahme der Kriminalität
die jetzt zu verzeichnen ist handelt es
sich um eine ganz andere Situation 15
Jahre nach der Wiedervereinigung erlebte
Deutschland erneut eine große
gesellschaftliche Herausforderung und
diesmal waren es nicht die Ossis die
Aufnahme von Millionen Einwanderern vor
allem aus dem Nahen Osten und Nordafrika
führte binnen weniger Jahre zu einer
drastischen Veränderung der ethnischen
kulturellen und auch sozialen
Zusammensetzung der Nation diese
bevölkerungsinfusion im Blitztempo
erfolgte auch noch in eine Gesellschaft
die sowieso schon durch die eher
mangelhafte Integration bestimmter
Einwanderergruppen aus anderen
Kulturräumen gekennzeichnet war was z.B
zu ihrer schlechten emanzipationsswerten
sogar in der zweiten und dritten
Einwanderergeneration führte und das
Ergebnis ist wiederum eine
gesellschaftliche präkarisierung die den
deutschen diesmal aber nicht durch eine
Besatzungsmacht aufgezwogen wurde und
die Frage fr lautet natürlich ist dies
wirklich die wahre Ursache für die
Explosion der Kriminalitätsraten sind es
diese schlecht integrierten Zuwanderer
die Deutschland in den Abgrund des
Verbrechens reißen oder ist die ganze
Geschichte doch etwas komplexer nun in
der Tat gibt es da noch eine weitere
bedeutende Komponente die die ganze
Mischung erst so richtig exlosiv macht
und eines kann ich euch schon mal
verraten die Antworten darauf liegen
durchaus auf dem Tisch allerdings
versucht die Regierung wie ihr gleich
sehen werdet diese nach Kräften zu
überdünchen also wollt ihr heute all
diese Antworten erfahren dann lasst uns
[Musik]
loslegen
Zahlensalat bevor wir ins Detail gehen
gibt es ein paar Dinge die ihr beachten
solltet zunächst einmal haben wir ein
wenig geschummelt ja die Kriminalität in
Deutschland ist gestiegen aber wir
sprechen natürlich immer noch von einem
europäischen Land die gemeldeten Zahlen
für raubüber Fälle und Tötungsdelikte in
Deutschland sind im weltweiten Vergleich
immer noch niedrig insgesamt ist
Deutschland immer noch ein recht
sicheres Land nicht zu vergleichen mit
den Zahlen aus den USA Lateinamerika
oder selbst Kanada Deutschland hat z.B
eine Mordrate von 0,76 Personen pro
100.000 Einwohner und das ist eigentlich
gar nichts es wäre eine traumzahl für
andere Länder wie die USA die einen Wert
von 6,8 ein Tötungsdelikten pro 100.000
Einwohnern melden das liegt fast zehn
Mal höher von Lateinamerika mal ganz so
schweigen wo diese Zahl im Jahr 2021 bei
19,91 lag und obwohl die Unterschiede in
anderen Bereichen der Kriminalität
geringer sind ist Deutschland immer noch
ein europäisches Land mit anderen Worten
in Sachen Kriminalität ist es den
amerikanischen Ländern um Lichtjahre
voraus und die Frage ist könnte sich das
vielleicht ändern nun das werden wir
gleich
[Musik]
sehen die zweite Sache über die wir uns
im Klaren sein müssen sind die
Auswirkungen der covid lockdowns ihre
wirtschaftlichen Folgen führten weltweit
zu einem allgemeinen Anstieg der
Kriminalität ihr wisst ja wie das ist
höhere Arbeitslosigkeit weniger
Einkommen mehr Unsicherheit Europa und
Deutschland waren dabei keine Ausnahmen
vergleicht man die Zahl der
Tötungsdelikte zwischen 2019 und 2020
liegt Deutschland an sechster Stelle in
der Region allerdings haben hier diese
Straftaten am stärksten zugenommen es
genügt ein Blick in die Rangliste um zu
sehen dass die Deutschen eine ähnliche
Entwicklung wie Malta Zypern oder
Portugal hatten also Länder mit denen
Berlin normalerweise nicht verglichen
wird und das Problem hier ist nicht dass
die Tötungsdelikte während der lockdowns
in die Höhe geschnellt sind sondern dass
sich dieser Trend in den nächsten Jahren
danach nicht umgekehrt hat passt auf
denn hier kommt die große Überraschung
während es Ländern wie Estland und
Litauen gelang den Anstieg der
Kriminalität umzukehren reichte der
Rückgang der Kriminalität in Deutschland
im Jahr 2021 nicht aus den deutschen
gelang es nicht den während der
lockdowns verzeichneten Anstieg
vollständig umzukehren in den Jahren
2022 und 23 verschlechterten sich die
Zahlen sogar noch weiter und genau das
ist die sor der deutschen Behörden
anders als in den Nachbarländern nimmt
die Kriminalität in Deutschland Jahr für
Jahr zu ohne dass es dafür eine klare
wirtschaftliche Ursache gibt aber die
Situation in unserer Stadt ist brisant
an vielen Orten ist die Situation
inzwischen unerträglich geworden Gewalt
Kriminalität Drogenhandel liegen dort an
der
Tagesordnung aber warum eigentlich so
viel Alarmismus wenn die Daten noch
erträglich zu sein scheinen nun wie wir
schon gesagt haben ist das was die
Experten am meisten beunruhigt die
anhaltende Tendenz es ist der
langfristige Trend die Entwicklung und
die Tatsache dass im Falle Deutschlands
in den letzten Jahren nicht nur die
tötungsdelekte zugenommen haben beim
Menschenhandel z.B liegt wie ihr sehen
könnt der Durchschnitt für den Zeitraum
2020 bis 22 um 55% höher als der für den
Zeitraum 2013 bis 2015 ein ähnliches
Problem stellen die Sexualstraftaten da
bis 2016 lag die Zahl der
Sexualstraftaten bei etwa 7000 pro Jahr
aber im Jahr 2018 lag sie bereit bei
11200 und im Jahr 2022 erreichten sie
mit
11896 ihren historischen Höchststand mit
anderen Worten die Zahl der
Sexualstraftaten ist in nur 5 Jahren um
70% gestiegen andere Straftaten wie
Raubüberfälle sowohl gewöhnliche als
auch durch Gewaltanwendung verschärfte
sind nach 5 Jahren des Rückgangs wieder
stark angestiegen und dies geschah
insbesondere nach der Aufhebung der
Corona lockdowns tja soweit so schlecht
aber nachdem wir die Zahlen geklärt
hätten lasst uns zur Kernfrage
zurückkehren was ist eigentlich die
Ursache für diesen Einstieg der
Kriminalität nun passt gut auf denn
jetzt kommt der interessanteste
[Musik]
Teil großer Teich große
Fische meine Lieben visualpolitik
Zuschauer wie heißt es doch so schön so
wie man seht so wird man ernten und
dieses Sprichwort scheint die
Inspiration für hunderte von kriminellen
Organisationen zu sein die in
Deutschland agieren einem Land dessen
staatliche Institutionen eigentlich zu
den stärksten der Welt gezählt werden
auch das deutsche Bundeskriminalamt
zeigt seit geraumer Zeit ein besonderes
Interesse an der organisierten
Kriminalität wenn wir von organisierter
Kriminalität sprechen meinen wir damit
kriminelle Organisationen den ganz
Europa über starke operative Kapazitäten
verfügen und neben Entführung Raub
Erpressung und Mord auch in
Finanzkriminalität großangelegten Betrug
und politisch und kulturell getriebene
Einschüchterung verwickelt sind all
diese Aktivitäten haben den letz Jahren
stark zugenommen mit anderen Worten wir
sprechen hier nicht von einfachen Dieben
oder Betrügern sondern von sehr
professionell strukturierten kriminellen
Großorganisationen regelrechten
verbrecherkonzerern mit Umsätzen im
Milliardenbereich und sie haben das
enorme Potenzial für das Wachstum der
verbrechensindustrie in Deutschland
schon vor Jahren erkannt und frühzeitig
mit zahlreichen Fördermaßnahmen begonnen
um die Rahmenbedingungen für ihre
dunklen Geschäfte zu optimieren und
ähnlich wie die Propagandamaschinerie
des Kremmel sorgen sie schon seit Jahren
sowohl für direkten Einfluss als auch
für die direkte Unterwanderung von Staat
und Gesellschaft von Behörden Medien und
NGOs um eine Politik durchzusetzen die
ihnen in die Hände spielt die Ergebnisse
der Arbeit ihrer Anwälte und Lobbyisten
konnte man in den letzten Jahren gut
beobachten die fast bedingungslose
Abschaffung von Grenzkontrollen
Abschiebung stopfs krimineller
Einwanderer unter absurden Begründungen
die Bürokratie und Ideologie getriebene
selbstobstruktion von Justiz und
Exekutive und allgemein ein fast schon
kafkesk oder gewollt anmutendes
ineffektives vor gehen gegen alle
Faktoren die einen Nährboden für
kriminelle Aktivitäten darstellen der
Zweck von Sozialsystemen die eigentlich
dazu dienen sollten Menschen vor
Abhängigkeit und dem Absturz in Armut
und Unterwelt zu bewahren wurde in ihr
Gegenteil verkehrt indem sie
integrationsfeindliche Anreize festigen
und arbeitsfähige Menschen vom legalen
Arbeitsmarkt fernhalten aber die Frage
ist woher kommen diese kriminellen
Gruppen überhaupt und was machen sie
stammen sie aus Deutschland oder dem
Ausland nun als erstes müssen wir
berücksichtigen dass nach Berichten der
deutschen Behörden selbst viele dieser
Gruppen in die sogenannte
clankriminalität verwickelt sind die
clanzugehörigkeit stellt dabei eine
verbindende die Tatbegehung fördernde
und die Aufklärung der Tat hindernde
Komponente da wobei die eigenen Normen
und Werte über die in Deutschland
geltende Rechtsordnung gestellt werden
können nach Angaben der deutschen
Behörden gibt es vier große Gruppen die
besonders auffallen zunächst einmal
wären da die großen lokalen Talente die
Outlaw Motorradgangs in Deutschland gibt
es rund 680 solcher Vereinigungen mit
insgesamt 7800 Mitgliedern in diesem
Segment stech Gruppen wie Banditos und
HS Angels hervor die in mehreren
europäischen Ländern verboten worduren
diese Gruppierungen sind hauptsächlich
mit mikroverbrechen wie Drogenhandel
Einschüchterung und Überfällen
beschäftigt und dann gibt es noch etwas
das als altes Klischee gelten könnte
aber dennoch eine harte Realität
darstellt die Rede ist von der
italienischen organisierten Kriminalität
den berüchtigten mafias offiziellen
Berichten zufolge ist die mit den mafias
verbundene organisierte kriminalit in
Deutschland im Jahr 2022 um 12,5%
gestiegen in diesem Fall geht es
hauptsächlich um Erpressung und
Drogenhandel ein dritter Stelle steht
die Kriminalität in Verbindung mit
russischen und eurasischen
Organisationen diese Organisationen
werden von Ländern aus dem ehemaligen
sowjetischen Orbit geleitet und
verwaltet und last but not least hätten
wen auch noch die syrischen
libanesischen und anderen arabischen
Clans deren Präsenz hat in den letzten
Jahren stark zugenommen und sie spielen
mittlerweile eine Schlüsselrolle im
Drogenhandel und der
Geldwäsche
in dieser Tabelle könnt ihr euch einen
Überblick über die wichtigsten
kriminellen Aktivitäten verschaffen die
all diese Gruppen und andere im Land
begehen die Form der angewandten Gewalt
ist sehr unterschiedlich verdeutlicht
aber das generelle Gewalt und
Bedrohungspotenzial der ok
grruppierungen sie reicht von verbalen
Drohungen über geiselnamen
Vergewaltigungen und
Körperverletzungsdelikten bis hin zu
Tötungsdelikten und versuchten
Tötungsdelikten sie richtet sich sowohl
gegen die Mitglieder der igenen
Gruppierung als auch gegen
rivalisierende ok Gruppierungen oder
Personen außerhalb der Gruppierung z.B
Familienangehörige mit Wohnsitz
innerhalb und außerhalb Deutschlands tja
schon wieder soweit so schlecht aber an
dieser Stelle müssten wir unweigerlich
zum heikelsten Punkt von allen kommen
nämlich der Rolle der Zuwanderung wie
ihr wahrscheinlich wisst zählt
Deutschland noch immer zu den größten
Befürworter der Aufnahme von Migranten
in Europa eine Position die dem Land
harte Auseinandersetzung mit Staaten wie
Polen Ungarn Tschechien der akei und
sogar Dänemark eingebrockt hat diese
Länder empfanden den enormen Druck aus
Berlin im gleichen lachsenstil
Zuwanderer aus prekären Regionen und
Bevölkerungsschichten aufzunehmen nicht
nur als Zumutung und hegemoniales Diktat
das an alte düstere Zeiten erinnerte
nein sie empfanden es teilweise geradezu
als eine Maßnahme zur Zersetzung der
Europäischen Union und wie ihr wisst
haben wir hier bei visualpolitik immer
eine migrationsfreundliche Position
vertreten wenn diese konstruktiv und
geregelt verläuft dass diese Länder
allerdings nicht ganz unrecht hatten
spiegelt sich nun natürlich in den
internationalen Rankings wieder in denen
die Sicherheit und peacefulness
einzelner Länder bewertet wird und in
denen gerade diese Staaten in letzten
Jahren an Deutschland vorbeigezogen sind
in Deutschland selbst werden medial beim
Thema Migration und Kriminalität eher
brutale Taten von integrationsunwilligen
thematisiert die entweder einzelne
Gruppen zuschlagen jedoch meist keinen
professionellen oder organisierten
Hintergrund vermuten lassen und so
schrecklich die Schicksale ihre Opfer
auch sind stellen sie doch nur die
Spitze des Eisbergs da eine Spitze die
eher zur Verzerrung der Wahrnehmung der
Realität führt denn die Daten sagen
durchaus etwas anderes insgesamt scheint
der Einstieg der Gewalt in Deutschland
vor allem mit kriminellen Gruppen
verbunden zu sein sie sind es die erst
aus dem Potenzial von Millionen von
Menschen aus Ländern mit ganz anderen
Kulturen schöpfen um sie in die
organisierte Unterwelt zu ziehen und das
ist noch nicht alles ein weiteres
wichtiges Merkmal ist dass all diese
Organisationen und jetzt haltet euch
fest ziemlich große Fans des
europäischen Projekts sind denn in
Wahrheit handelt es sich nicht um ein
isoliert deutsches Problem ganz im
Gegenteil sie haben ihre kriminellen
Netze über den gesamten alten Kontinent
verwoben so scheinen kriminelle
Organisationen in Deutschland sehr enge
Beziehungen zu ihren pondons in den
Niederlanden und Spanien zu unterhalten
also Ländern mit einem hohen Anteil an
Seehandel und dieser ist natürlich
direkt mit dem Drogenhandel verbunden
die Beziehungen zu Gruppen in der Türkei
haben wiederum mit Menschenhandel zu tun
und selbst die Schweiz ist ein wichtiger
Knotenpunkt und zwar wenn es um
Geldwäsche und Finanzkriminalität geht
und in dieser Hinsicht sind die
Niederlande einer der Fälle die den
deutschen Behörden die größten Sorgen
bereiten warum nun weil sie die Achse
amsterdambrüssel als Einfallstor für den
Drogenhandel sehen das großen Druck auf
das Justizsystem ausübt und natürlich
haben sie Angst dass diese Situation
auch auf Deutschland übergreift wir
sehen eine Entwicklung die aus den
Niederlanden in Schweden schon sichtbar
ist die immer brutaler wird wir haben in
den Niederlanden leider die Situation
dass dort schon Staatsanwälte erschossen
wurden oder es gab Folterkammern die
gefunden wurden im Zusammenhang mit
organisierter
Kriminalität an dieser Stelle wird klar
dass die kriminalitätsprobleme in
Deutschland ziemlich einzigartig sind
sie haben zwar ebenso mit
wirtschaftlicher Marginalität mangelnden
Anreizen zur Integration in die legale
Berufswelt oder institutionelle Schwäche
zu tun das sind die typischen Zutaten
aber auch mit der Tatsache dass die
teutonische Nation zur Operationsbasis
für eine Reihe von europäischen
verbrecherbossen geworden ist diese sind
nicht nur bestens vernetzt sondern haben
ihre Zöglinge schon vor einiger Zeit auf
den Marsch durch die Institution
geschickt dadurch wollen sie in einigen
Jahren die vollständige Kontrolle über
bestimmte Bereiche des deutschen Staats
ernten tja aber was tut die deutsche
Regierung um diese Situation zu ändern
nun es gibt eine Menge Diagnostiker aber
kaum jemanden der den Mut hat den
deutschen Patienten die harte aber
notwendige Therapie zu verordnen denn
passt gut auf in Berlin scheint es mehr
Zweifel als Gewissheit darüber zu geben
wie man diesem Problem begegnen kann
ohne dabei sein Interessengruppen auf
die Füße zu
[Applaus]
[Musik]
treten der Elefant im
Raum im Moment fallen die Diagnosen der
deutschen Behörden zum Anstieg der
Kriminalität gelinde gesagt eher
zurückhaltend aus zunächst einmal
glauben die Sprecher der
Strafverfolgungsbehörden dass die
aktuellen Statistiken aufgrund der
veränderten sozialen Gewohnheiten im
Zuge der Corona lockdowns schwer zu
vergleichen sind die für 2022
registrierten Zahlen zur Kriminalität in
Deutschland sind nur bedingt mit denen
aus den beiden Vorjahren vergleichbar
denn die coronamaßnahmen haben auch das
kriminalitätsgeschehen stark beeinflusst
die 2022 registrierten Fallzahlen liegen
in Relation zu den aus 2019 dem letzten
Jahr vor der Pandemie auf vergleichbarem
Niveau das relativiert den im Vergleich
mit 2021 zu konstatierenden starken
Anstieg ein wesentlicher Grund für den
Anstieg der Fallzahlen dürfte der
Wegfall der coronabeschränk und damit
einhergehend die Rückkehr ins normale
öffentliche Leben sein mehr
wiedergewonnene Freiheit bedeutet auch
mehr tatgelegenheiten für kriminelle das
Problem dabei nun dass dies nichts
weiter als eine Ausrede zu sein scheint
ihr müsst nämlich verstehen dass durch
die Rückkehr zur Normalität viele
Verbrechen wieder begangen werden
konnten aber das würde bestenfalls die
Rückkehr auf das Niveau von 2019
erklären allerdings hat die Entwicklung
das Niveau vor der Pandemie weit
überschritten hierbei scheint es sich
also nicht um eine vernünf Erklärung zu
handeln wenn wir die Mordrate
ausklammern sind praktisch alle anderen
Straftaten im Vergleich zu 2019
erheblich gestiegen hinzu kommt dass
viele Straftaten bereits seit 2018 einen
deutlichen Zuwachs verzeichnen die
Erklärung der deutschen Regierung
scheint also nichts weiter als eine
Nebelkerze zu sein sie nutzt die
Pandemie aus um eine sehr negative
Entwicklung zu verschleiern denn wie wir
gesehen haben hängt das größte Problem
nicht mit den Lockdown zusammen sondern
mit der Konsolidierung der Macht vieler
krimineller Organisationen in
Deutschland und das meine Lieben
Zuschauer lässt er an dass den deutschen
das Schlimmste noch bevorsteht die
Mafiosi verfügen über immer mehr
Ressourcen und Mittel mit denen sie
Politik Medien und Verwaltung in die
Richtung lecken können die ihren
Absichten und Strukturen am meisten
zuträglich ist hierzu zählen Bestechung
Erpressung Klientelismus Nepotismus
Infiltration und so weiter und so fort
haben Sie die jeweiligen
Schlüsselposition erstmal unter ihre
Kontrolle gebracht drehen sie subtil
aber wirksam so an den en Schrauben dass
die Kriminalitätsbekämpfung durch den
Staat weiter zurückgefahren wird und
gleichzeitig all jene Faktoren gefördert
werden die Kriminalität begünstigen es
ist eine Methode die wir bereits in
vielen anderen Staaten wie Italien
Lateinamerika oder Russland gesehen
haben die tatsächlichen
Kriminalitätsraten in Deutschland
dürften also nicht nur weiter zunehmen
nein die zunehmende institutionelle
Zersetzung und Unterwanderung könnte
auch dazu führen dass Realität und
Statistiken immer weiter auseinander
trifften mit anderen Worten wenn nichts
unternommen wird könnte der derzeitige
Ausbruch der verbrechenspandemie für
immer bestehen
bleiben wie wir bereits gesehen haben
gibt es ab 2020 mindestens 100
Organisationen mehr als vor den Corona
lockdowns das erklärt warum das Jahr
2023 von Nachrichten wie diesen geprägt
war 3 mai 2023 Deutschland und Italien
gehen mit ratzien und Verhaftungen gegen
die italienische Mafia vor 29 juni 2023
Österreich beschlagnammt großes
Waffenlager bei raazia bei
rechtsextremen Biker 26 September 2023
13 Angeklagte werden im Prozess gegen
die Hells Angels freigesprochen und 32
weitere zu Haftstrafen von bis zu Z
Jahren verurteilt damit stehen die
deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden vor ihrer
größten Herausforderung seit der
Wiedervereinigung eine Herausforderung
die zunehmend systemischen Charakters
ist die Frage ist also denkt ihr dass
diese kriminellen Organisation nun ein
fester Teil Deutschlands sein werden und
große Teile der Macht im Lande an sich
reißen können wie z.B die italienischen
mafias in Italien wie würdet ihr mit
diesem Problem umgehen wie immer sind
wir auf eure Meinung zu diesem
hochgradig brisanten Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dies Video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht auch das
daraus gelernt habt falls ja gibt ih
bitte ein Like und teilt es mit euren
Freunden um es auch mit Ihnen zu
diskutieren natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit un dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
zu dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]